Hi, my name is Franklin Kalk. I'm 60 years old. I live in
Austin, Texas. I took Warfarin for six months, about three years ago. I
had a blood clot probably due to heavy travel. There were no other
complicating symptoms or at least that was what we surmised at the time.
>> Now when you say you had a blood clot that, you know,
to anyone who hasn't had a blood clot before that sounds kind of serious.
Is that serious?
>> It is, and it was kind of an interesting I mean I'll tell you the long
version, right? it started out, I in retrospect, probably for several months,
>> Mm-hm.
>> I had some developing issues, but didn't really know it at the time.
>> But looking back after, after I discovered it
it became pretty clear that I had, you know,
had had these these symptoms. You know, I didn't
really know anything about blood clots. I have to
say, I wasn't educated about them at all. I,
I'm a little better educated now, of course, but at
the time, I really didn't know anything. once the pain moved
from my calf to my groin, I kind of, you know, figured out. Oh, wait
a minute, this isn't just a muscle pull, and it's really tender.
I mean you, I couldn't touch it without it being pretty painful, so
That was a little bit. You know, muscle pulls don't really feel that way.
With muscle pull, if you, you know, if you really massage, maybe okay. But
I mean, just, light touch, I could feel it. So it was something different.
>> Well, after you have the
[INAUDIBLE]
and you were able to sort of bust up the initial clot.
>> Right.
>> The warfarin was prescribed to, essentially, prevent clots
from forming for a period of time in the future.
>> Right.
>> Now, is this a pill that you had to
take every day? Well, first off, is it a pill?
>> It's a pill.
>> And is it something you had to take every day?
>> Right, it's a pill. You take it every day. and I'm
trying to remem-, I can't remember exactly whether I actually took more
than one in a day to ramp up to
some level or not. I don't remember, but. It took
about two weeks to determine that I was stable
on it, that my, my clotting factors were at a
normal level and not varying a lot' cause that's
one of the things they look for. so I had
to get you know, blood tests every, every twice a
week for two weeks and then every week after that.
But it's a pill and you know long term over six months I took it once a day.
>> And so obviously, I guess, the concern
is since the warfarin itself modulates the clotting factors,
and how effective and efficient they work for you,
that too much warfarin could be a bad thing.
>> Absolutely, yeah.
>> So, when your doctor prescribed this for
you, what were the considerations that went into I
mean, did he have lots of special instructions for you, did he try to get a lot
of information from you, did you have to modify anything in your life
>> Right.
>> To accommodate the dosing?
>> yes, all of the above. He gave me some fairly, they weren't super
detailed, but fairly detailed instructions. I, you
know once I discovered and had verified it.
[LAUGH]
The doctor, that I had a clot. And that I was,
you know? because these shots will remind you, if nothing else. because
compared to the shots, or warfarin itself, was not really a
big deal for me in terms of the, you know, the ingestion.
>> Sure.
>> More or less, cursorily went over the instructions with me,
rather than go through them word by word. Because he know
I had read them, and had begun to educate myself, and
I was lucky because my personal physician was also my next
store neighbor. So he knew my lifestyle and knew that I was
going to be, you know, pretty diligent
about understanding this, you know, this condition.
>> Mm-hm. What were some of the special
exceptions we know that vitamin K is really important.
>> Right.
>> rather the amounts of vitamin K, it
was vitamin K as an essential component for clotting.
>> Right.
>> So did you have to alter your diet or did you have to pay special
attention to it?
>> Yes. So before, and this is another interesting sort
of predetermining factor, I think. Not just the travel but I
ate a lot of leafy green vegetables which have, those are
really the main sources in our normal diet of vitamin K.
for example iceberg lettuce doesn't have much but
romaine does, right. Kale has enormous amounts. Spinach, I
love spinach. I, I ate a lot of spinach before that. So I had to cut back
and I really, I didn't eliminate them from my diet, but I cut way back. And I
did control very carefully, the intake. So I, I
knew exactly how much I was taking each day.
There were some things I totally eliminated
from my diet. For example avocados, and
the reason for that is, avacados you can have two avocados that look the same.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But yet one will have very little vitamin K
and the other one can have enormous amount per unit weight.
So the, the variability was just is something that you know
you would, you just imagine, well I'm not going to eat those
then, right? Because I don't want to inject that kind
of variability in to my diet. In fact when I
had the weekly blood test one thing I noticed right
away was that the bleeding did not stop. Just a little
pin prick in the finger is, is what was needed
to get the blood test taken. So, you know, you can
usually just do this with your fingers for two or
three minutes and then the blood will stop, right? But it
would take thirty minutes or more, because we were
trying to keep my blood relatively thin the other thing,
the other lifestyle change for me was I like to
drive cars fast at the racetrack and I couldn't do
that anymore because of the concern about blunt force trauma.
Any kind of accident, you know, if you have a
bad bruise you could, you know, potentially bleed to death
if your blood doesn't clot well. So, you know, that's,
that's the kind of thing that you know, really was a big change for me. For me
personally, I stopped traveling for about six to
eight weeks and then after that I remember still
the first aircraft that I got on. I
was fidgeting, and it was Austin to Dallas, you
know, literally a 35 minute flight and then
I went Dallas to Milwaukee. So maybe an hour,
right? Not very far. I was fidgeting the
whole time just trying to keep my blood flowing
[LAUGH].
I mean it's, it really changes your attitude. I mean,
for me it was my first, glimpse of mortality, right?
So I mean that was, that was a big deal.
And I think also, you know just having to go
through a dietary change for the first time in my
life and strictly control my diet You know, my attitude
had always been, I'll eat as much as I want,
anything I want, I'll just exercise to, to keep my weight,
you know, where I want it. It wasn't like that any more.
>> Uh-huh.
>> So that was a big change. And, you know, it was
a big change for my family, because now all of a sudden, if
we were, if they were going to have Kale or spinach, I wasn't.
So it was almost like we had to cook for two different diets.
>> mm.
>> Right? So I mean and just things like that, I mean
that was, that was part of it. But I think also there was
probably some worry, you know, from the other family members about, you know, is
dad okay or is my husband okay, right? When I read about Warfarin I thought
Well, you know, a couple of things. It's a lot like aspirin, it was
discovered quite a while ago, well, early
in the last century. Maybe 1930's or 20's.
it's amazing that such an effective drug has
not really had yet, a replacement that works, kind of
for everybody. You know what I mean? that was
interesting to me. because it has been used really
for other purposes than treating blood clots before
that. At first I thought I'm not sure I
want to put this in my body but it really
wasn't all that bad. The actual ingestion of the,
of the drug itself. I really felt nothing
and, you know, I felt perfectly normal. so
that was good. And I think there you know don't fear, right? On the other hand
for me I, I stabilized rapidly and, and
you know my my clotting factor levels stayed
very constant over time. Maybe that was just
discipline. So my advice would be, follow a,
a diet, you know, be really strict about your diet. That
doesn't mean, you know, deprive yourself but, but be consistent with
it, so that your, your, your body is being presented with
the same chemistry from nutrition. I mean, I think that's really important.